boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sake on so
excited to be talking about post quantum
IOT security we have Paul claisen
joining us on the show hello hello
thanks for coming on Paul really
appreciate it nice to be here I'm super
excited for this big shout out to Steve
weight for introducing us yeah
great guy great guy and I'm so pumped
this topic is really important as we
move into the IOT era and into the
security side of that and also into
quantum computing for those who don't
know Paul's background a CEO of agile P
Q which developed IOT security that
survives in a quantum computing era and
you can find the link in the bio below
agile PQ comm as well as LinkedIn
profile Paulus nothing's off of one of
our favorite questions to ask our guests
what are your thoughts in the direction
of our world direction of our world you
know I guess I could use the term it's
the best of times and the worst of times
so you have all of this technology that
is going to help humanity everything all
kinds of things in energy in sensors
that can be able to help our world in so
many directions but it's also used by
bad actors that can use those kinds of
things for clandestine purposes we've
got the best of times when prosperity is
amazing where people have money and and
food and happiness in a lot of ways but
there are still so many tragic
situations around the world
everything from vas still vast hunger in
some places to children who are at risk
to human trafficking to all kinds of
things that we are grappling with in
this world and it seems like there are
times when the faster we go to create
good situations in the world the faster
that a negative aspect grows as well so
we've got a lot of work to do
but there's a lot of hope in this world
yeah that's actually a frequently
reoccurring point from people on the
shows it's the best of times and then
some crazy ways the worst of times and
so how do we win this wisdom race where
we have all these democratization of all
these exponential technologies but we
also have to level up our wisdom our
ability to maximize prosperity to know
how to play well together and so what
would be maybe a core principle that you
would recommend people to embody as we
move forward well look I believe in
humanity I believe that humans are
ultimately innately good and if they
perpetrate bad acts it's because likely
they were taught those bad acts in some
way along their life so the perpetuation
of education the perpetuation of ethics
the perpetuation of goodness in the
world is absolutely critical from the
time that a baby is born yeah and if we
can instill those kinds of feelings and
in human beings right from the start
then life gets much better it's just
that there are so many disadvantaged
civilizations and disadvantaged cultures
that that start out life in a very
difficult situation and often times it
can lead to difficult circumstances
within the world yeah this is so
critical this moment as the child is
born into the world there's so much that
comes from it ancestrally and then also
those first key months as it's laying
down its first inputs that it takes in
to have enough love and compassion food
water air shelter the basic needs
electricity education then that's that's
the thing is that it's taught bad
malevolence is taught and so if there is
a way to to propagate more education
around goodness and a ground ethics and
morality these types of things then we
can figure out how to cooperate and
prosper more effectively I like that a
lot
Paul let's talk about your journey who
were you growing up how did you get
interested in the fields that you're in
today yeah so growing up I grew up on a
very small farm and cattle ranch in
Idaho I was an adopted child adopted
when I was three days old and and grew
up with an older brother and two younger
sisters who were adopted my mother could
not have children biologically but boy
you would never know it in our household
we had more love more nurturing more
help more strength in our home than you
can ever imagine we were as poor as we
could be on the small farm I didn't know
that
it was an amazing amazing childhood and
I grew up just knowing ethics and
knowing goodness and knowing to be good
to other people and being wakened in the
middle of the night by my father and
saying come on our neighbors barn is
burning we're going down to help put the
fire out and keep keep the embers from
going to his haystacks in his home and
other buildings and so we grew up being
neighbors we grew up helping people and
what an amazing amazing upbringing I had
it was I couldn't have had a better
upbringing it was it was truly amazing
and just as an interesting side note I
never did no birth family until one year
ago right now and I took a DNA test and
when I got the results back it's a long
story but I was reading the I took the
test for a medical profile and got the
medical profile back and was reading
that and I was on a business trip and my
wife said are there any birth relatives
it hadn't occurred to me to look I was
just reading the medical profile and I
looked and there was a birth sister and
two birth brothers listed their
half-brothers and half-sisters and and
through that experience without going
into all of the long details within 30
days I had met flown to
met online then spoken with on the phone
and then flew to meet birth family on
both my father and my mother's side and
my birth father had passed away but my
birth mother is still living
she lives in Olympia Washington and I've
met her and now and seen her many times
and I thought the question the first
question she ever asked me when she got
on the phone with me was this way
she said have you had a good life are
you okay I've worried every day of my
life that I gave you away and it wasn't
the right thing to do and I was able to
assure this beautiful woman that she for
whatever reason couldn't if she couldn't
raise me that she did an amazing thing
for me because I had such an incredible
impeccable early years in my life so
that's the early stage Paul that's such
an interesting story so when you grew up
it was on rural mrs. Idaho a rural Idaho
okay rural Idaho and you had a bird you
had an on another adopted brother and
sister two sisters and a brother yes
sisters and a brother so you have four
total adopted children in this family
Wow
yeah and then Wow and from three days
old from three days old when I was a DA
and I don't know and so then as you're
growing up with them you said that you
were given you know you all love and
what you needed from the from the
adoption from the parents I developed at
you and then it was like hard for for
people to see or you didn't really feel
like it was an adoptive family it felt
like it was a biological family
that's such that's like that's when I
think the like so important because then
that then the adoption like feels like
it's you know I recall in an instance
when I was in grade school when just as
children sometimes naturally do but they
were really giving me a bad time because
everyone knew that I was adopted in this
small farming community and I never knew
a time when I didn't know that I was
adopted but but to me this was my family
and my
my mother and my father but at some some
you know out on the playground some kids
were giving me a bad time about being
adopted and that I was found on the side
of the road and all the kinds of things
that they can do and I came in in the
second grade and my secondary teacher
looked at me and she said are you okay
and I burst out in tears because I I
didn't know how to handle that and she
knelt down by me and asked me what was
wrong and I told her what had been said
and she stood up and I'll never forget
her telling the whole class you guys
have no idea what his parents had to go
through to get him and they loved him as
much as any parent would love their own
child and it was a great learning
experience for the entire class and it's
it absolutely solidified in me that I'm
okay yeah I'm just fine that things
happen in life but how you build those
and and surmount those difficulties
means everything yeah yeah and how you
have a mentor or a teacher that can help
helped you along the way looks you long
the way and help the whole class learn
that alone yeah of course um those are
pretty pivotal moments it almost it
helped you with your with who you were
true truly with embodying who you were
and rather than meeting to like bury it
aside to fit in or whatever yeah that's
so important and then also it's
interesting that your biological mother
said that that she worried about you
everyday and that that you if you were
okay and how to say this whole life all
that type of things and then you just
recently found that out through DNA
testing you know there's very
interesting things that science is able
to unveil for us and that's well that's
one of them there's this ancestry so
then what about your interest in science
and technology and the fields that led
you to agile p/q how did all these
things develop who were you well I spent
a period of time coming out of college
involved in politics I ran a
congressional campaign and went to
Washington I was chief of staff to two
congressmen in Washington and worked for
the White House doing what's called
advance work setting up details when
they would travel and and taking him
through the the events as they would
travel and so forth I was not too
involved in policy at the White House
but I learned
an awful lot about that and I've
remained active in politics ever since
working on campaigns being campaign
chairman if people have run for Senate
in the house and governor and various
other things and sat on presidential
campaign committees that's been an
active part of my life but through all
of that I after I left Washington DC I
wanted to get into business and I went
into the investment business and I
learned corporate finance and business
being involved in that then I wanted to
move to the operating side and a friend
a very dear friend a wonderful man had
started a technology company and speech
recognition software and he invited me
to come and join him in his company as a
vice president and I did that and
started running around the world trying
to look for a variety of development
contracts for that speech recognition
and then since then I've had the
opportunity to go into different kinds
of really leading-edge technologies and
started serving as a CEO and growing
these companies and putting money behind
them putting people behind them and
growing these leading-edge technologies
and it's been it's been a journey
because it hasn't been only in software
it's been in software nanotechnology
solar energy a variety of different
industries and it's been a it's been a
real ride it's been a lot of fun taking
those companies growing them getting
them to the next stage and and moving
forward yeah very multidisciplinary
Polymathic tons of different fields of
science and technology especially
politics to in DC to kind of learning
about how that works
yeah these different these are like
different engines of change and to know
how they work makes you more well
and also grows your emotional
intelligence skills because you have to
learn how to relate to people in the
political sphere in growing companies
investing in companies that are trying
to make different impacts so then what
about what led to Ben agile BQ well I
had been working in a company that I had
grown and it was getting to a larger
point we hired a new CEO who had a PhD
in nanotechnology and and then I started
doing some consulting for investors who
would say could you come into this
company and help get it commercial or in
a couple of cases turn it around or find
a workout for a company so I did that
for a while and then a friend invited me
to look at this company he had had a
35-year career at Intel had been
contacted by agile PQ to see if they
could find some markets and do some
things a really good group of people who
had founded agile PQ but I think the
timing was right for maybe the board and
the invest in the early investors who
were more family investors angels family
and friends to maybe look to someone who
had been there and done that before
helped to bring the company to the next
phase of pulling it into commercial
launch so I went in at first and did
some consulting provided a report very
shortly thereafter they asked me to step
in as CEO and then I really looked at
the markets very strongly very much in
depth and I decided to do it this is a
phenomenal technology phenomenal
opportunity that the timing is right
it's it's a great opportunity so I
stepped in a couple of years ago and we
launched the product a year ago now and
got a handful of beta customers last
year and now we're in full commercial
launch and and doing well whoa okay so
then what did you guys release that last
year
where is this being deployed teaches
about it so we released a technology
that is a full security encryption
technology with a total footprint of two
kilobytes so that means that total
encryption security can reside on the
smallest of what are called IOT devices
Internet of Things these are very small
computing devices connected to the
Internet and mostly they are machine to
machine communication so it's a very
small device communicating with the
server collecting data sometimes it can
be as small as an off on switch
sometimes it can be a thermostat on a
wall that you run from your smartphone
sometimes it can be a sensor that's
sensing something on a manufacturing
floor whether that be vibration of a
motor heat light any all kinds of of
sensors they are now are connected to
the Internet which provides massive
amounts of data and allows for greater
quality of products greater security in
some cases but those very small devices
are so small that they cannot run
traditional security there's not enough
computing power not enough memory and in
fact some of them have a total of a
hundred kilobytes in processing power on
those very small devices well today's
encryption that's run on your smart
phone that encryption takes three
megabytes to encode and three Benga
bytes to decode a message going in and
out that can't operate on us on these
small what are called class zero class
one class two devices so our company
came along and very bright engineers
created a new security for a new
computing age and that new security is
more secure than that legacy technology
which is called AES TLS advanced
encryption standard
transport layer system AES TLS Tecna
ecology it's more secure it's up to 10
times faster it uses far less battery
power it's just a phenomenal
revolutionary change in encryption and
security technology all right so let's
break down some of the nuance so then
you have it's a substitute software it's
it's packaged in two kilobytes is the
size correct of the software and then
then that goes on IOT devices it does
and the IOT devices have a
classification in terms of size like
you've got zeros smallest the smallest
and what's the largest class size oh I
don't even know but a smartphone is
roughly a class three sometimes a class
four device okay so got it so three or
four is on smartphone level so class
zero is like is like we're talking a
grain of rice yeah yeah it's very very
small chipset less than a hundred
kilobytes in processing very little
memory so it would be it would be
analogous to a chipset that's say on a
nest thermostat on your wall so then
something let's say that the chipset in
a nest thermostat or the chipset in any
of the other sensing sensors in like you
were describing earlier in the factories
for machines that are constantly up
watching machines or any camera sensors
on maybe autonomous vehicles or wherever
right we want to make sure that what
information that camera is seeing when
it's looking at the road is then as the
data is being transmitted to the server
and being in which is potentially you
know just cloud computing the what the
what the camera is seeing and then
making decisions in millisecond time
frames that Kerr you need to then run
that data that camera sensing data
through your encryption which only takes
two kilobytes your encryption your
encrypting it then you're sending it to
the server for which needs to then
decrypt it to run the computation yeah
so so you use a key you in essence
obfuscate the data you scramble it
send the message in it scripted form
then there's a key on the back end that
will decode the message it's received by
the server and then it can continue to
send messages back and forth what those
small devices are lacking today is that
kind of encryption full encryption on a
very small device there are some
technologies that people believe our
security like a simple authentication
and authorization the server says to an
IOT device is are you the right device
the IOT of devices yep that's me and
then it authorizes a data stream to go
back and forth that's called
authorization and authentication and
authorization
sometimes small IOT devices will have
that sometimes they don't the vast
majority of the billions of IOT devices
that are already deployed across the
world have zero zero security on them no
security on them whatsoever
so if you've got a smart thermostat in
some cases smart doorbells in some cases
smart consumer goods or in sensors on a
factory floor or all all kinds of IOT
devices they just simply don't have
security and in some cases there's just
a lack of education about why that's
even important people say well it's only
this amount of data why would we ever
worry about that there's massive number
of reasons why people can be
tremendously exposed in the corporate
risk it goes up by having an exposed
computing device connected to the
Internet
yes okay so then the actual process of
securing these data streams is extremely
important and then also that you call
this slim secure last Internet mile and
then that's also for both the last
Internet mile but also it's slim as and
the actual tech is 2 kilobytes so yeah
yeah ideas yeah yeah secure secure last
IOT mile IOT mile although in today's
world these devices are so small we
sometimes joke that it's really not no
longer an IOT mile it's an IOT inch
I mean these devices are so small and
there's they're so constrained on
computing power and battery power and
various other things yeah okay so the
constraining aspects of these class 0
class 1 IRT devices they're super small
the chipset it's not really able to take
on a whole lot of processing capacities
on board itself so it's it's really
trying to just take in the data that
it's having and then encrypting it with
that key and then giving it to the
server which has the other side of the
key to be able to decrypt it yes and
does that key change
oh yes the key changes every how often
does it change well this is an
interesting thing so in an Aes a
standard legacy security type system
they may create a key at the beginning
of a message a key at the end of the
message and those keys rotate or change
through a variety of messages so that
even if somebody were to break one
message they would have to break the
code again to get to the next message
that's what's made encryption quite
secure over the years however with our
technology we use a much larger key now
that doesn't seem intuitive if we have a
much smaller footprint how do you have a
bigger key well we reduced the size of
the operating code dramatically from 3
megabytes down to 2 kilobytes and that
allows us to have 2 kilobytes of
operating code plus a much longer key
that makes us far more secure in terms
of that key number one those keys are
keys are long enough that they won't be
able to be broken by a quantum computer
in the future as quantum computing age
begins to become reality here it's
pretty much well accepted that current
encryption technology will be broken by
quantum computers ours will not and
that's one reason the second thing is is
current technology uses a key at the
beginning of a
a message at key at the end we break
that message up into much smaller bite
sizes and put a key at the beginning of
the end of each bite not at the
beginning and the end of each message
and we rotate those keys continually
that also gives us a distinct advantage
in a quantum computing environment so so
this becomes some things that we do that
are strong competitive advantages that
are built into our algorithms that allow
us to operate and will protect people as
quantum computing becomes pervasive okay
and one more time on the two important
pieces that enable you so size of the
security key size of the key yep okay
and both the size of the message that's
being transmitted and where the keys are
placed in those messages and how often
they're wrote able often the keys are
rotating and how often their place in
the messages yes and how long each key
is yes okay so that's kind of some of
the proprietary it is how we do that and
what we do and size of keys and how we
do that with great with great agility
and and great speed as part of our our
proprietary technology okay okay yeah
it's always interesting thinking but on
a technical side how computer scientists
and encryption specialists are figuring
this stuff out yeah yeah it's
sophisticated technology but things are
happening communications are happening
so fast I mean the things are going back
and forth so fast but in the future
they're going to get faster and they
have we have to be able to communicate
securely and have to be able to
communicate with great speed in the
future to keep up with technology I can
tell you bad actors are figuring this
out as fast as the white hat actors are
we have a young man on our staff who's
just absolutely brilliant cryptologist
he's one of the four best hackers white
hat hackers in the world
and and he stresses all the time how
critical it is that we come up with new
ways new methods and new standards to
have security systems for this IOT
freight train it's an interesting fact
that in 2018 the number of these small
IOT devices surpassed the number of
other computing form factors combined
throughout the world so all of the
smartphones laptops desktops servers IOT
devices now make up more computers than
all of those in the world and IOT only
really started in earnest about five
years ago so the technology adoption has
been just vast well we're not keeping up
- the computing growth with security
growth and with some other factors but
primarily security growth to fit those
form factors and so we're we've done
that and now we're coming out of
obscurity telling people about what
we're doing and we launched our product
last year finished up our beta accounts
got everything going and now we're in
full commercial mode with our technology
and already we've been signed up to be
on over 300 million devices in the next
three years
300 million devices and there's there's
the numbers are all over the board on
IOT but some people estimate that
there's already somewhere between 15 and
20 billion devices IOT devices in the
world and that's projected to go to 50
billion by 2021 and some in some
projections yeah some go higher than
that some are lower the projections
nobody really knows what they do know is
there's gonna be a lot of devices and
within the next five years 80% of the
world's computers will be these small
IOT devices yeah so we better get real
about putting security on these things
yeah
it's crazy that in just the last five
years that IOT devices have overcome the
amount of computers and cellphones that
we have that's crazy and now that the
estimates are to be in the tens of
billions in the next couple of years
it's like securing those data streams
making sure that you have the top edge
people on board that can the white hat
white hat meaning white hat hackers
there are good people hacking trying to
see if they can break down the so people
hire white hat hackers all the time to
go in and say hack our system see if you
can get into it and show us where our
vulnerabilities are because they want
those hackers to be as good as the bad
actors to make sure that they can find
holes in the systems and plug those
holes before data critical data is
stolen or in some cases money or or
those kinds of things but there are
weekly there are news articles about
hacks that have taken place because of
holes and systems so yeah that's that's
what a white hat hacker it is yeah and
then it makes sense to have that on your
team to constantly be seeing if if you
what you're making and how hard it is to
hack into it to continue making it
better and better over time
interesting now this can be used in any
protocol RFID Bluetooth cellular we any
communications protocol we can use we
can because of software we have already
integrated with and ported to all kinds
of protocols we've prepared the
technology for mass market by
integrating with a large number of IOT
chipsets already we can operate in
multiple languages so we have a toolkit
that people can get we have ten free
seats on that toolkit people can get
that develop it into their product and
then sign a commercial license
when they're ready to go to market with
their technology we we don't have to go
only on new products we can them we can
flash our technology to existing IOT
devices so it's a pretty nimble program
okay and then what about you were
mentioning the speeds too so what does
it mean to be like 8 to 10 times faster
and to have 1/10 data what are those
yeah so there is a technology called
transport layer system that requires a
certain amount of data to connect the
transport of data from point to point
from machine to machine it takes a
certain amount of size data code in size
to connect that data our technology uses
1/10 the data of the standard TLS we had
to create a new transport layer system
for us that this kind of tunnels right
through the existing transport layer and
in connects and less data with less data
because our code is so much smaller it's
efficient that lends to having a much
faster processing speed because we're
fast and nimble and smaller code size we
don't use nearly as much battery power
oh I think the projection there or the
the estimate is about 80% of IOT devices
in the future will be battery-powered
not hardwired so they're not gonna have
unlimited power you don't want to run
that battery down running a security
system because then you're gonna have to
change the battery or change the device
regularly so you can wirelessly charge
to the device well some I'm sure you can
but most of them are gonna be battery
and when when the battery runs out
they'll either change it or in most
cases these are throwaway devices you
take the device off put a new device on
and and run it for another two to three
years on battery power so you just can't
have encryption and security systems
that run that battery down quicker
because it becomes costly and it becomes
difficult to replace those devices too
often and then that also is the that's
both the speed and the data both on both
that side yes that explains both of
those things I'm so so trying to
understand this so I apologize it is
rather sophisticated what takes place
yeah okay so then the speed is faster
because because we have a very small
code we're able to process that code
encode and decode encrypt and decrypt
much much faster okay using smaller code
sizes okay and then the the data is less
because it's well the DS well because of
the way we've configured the algorithms
we came up with a new encryption system
that that can process that data much
much more efficiently and then what
about the post quantum side of things so
when we have that much compute how can
you withstand yeah so quantum computers
are on their way they're under
development now and they're being used
there's quantum computers in the u.s. at
NASA and various IBM and other places
there's quantum computers in Canada and
in in China and various other areas that
have technological development and a
quantum computer processes data in an
entirely different way than a current
computer does our current computer uses
what's called binary code ones and zeros
to do programming a quantum computer
uses a whole new programming language
called qubits in fact it sees a 1 and a
0 is the exact same symbol and and we
don't have time to go in how quantum
computers work but in certain cases in
certain and for certain functions it can
process massive amounts of data much
faster much more streamlined and there
will be huge benefits to have in quanti
quantum computing in the future but it
also presents problems like any new
technology doesn't want
problems is it can process data so
quickly that it's estimated it can break
current computing systems so when we
built our system we built it with with
larger keys so let's say an aes key that
to encode a message and to decode on the
back end is much smaller than ours so a
quantum computer can crunch through all
of the different possibilities in those
numbers to come up to crack that code of
that key they could crunch through that
data so fast that they could break that
so our key space the entire universe of
possible key combinations is 429 orders
of magnitude larger than the current
security system because our keys are so
much bigger that key space is larger
that that it's it's mathematically we
can show how that kind of a key space
cannot be broken by a quantum computer
ok so so it's both a compression
algorithm that enables you to make these
massive keys compressed down and then
it's also then how difficult it is for
something with that much of a key space
to be able to be penetrated by a quantum
group one nuance it's not really
compression technology it's the way we
use those keys in a way the algorithm
processes those and and yeah yeah so the
key space has to be a certain amount of
size to be secure and so you you don't
want to compress that down with two
smaller number of symbols or a smaller
number but but the algorithm itself
processes that code in a very efficient
way even though our key space is larger
our processing code is much smaller okay
okay
key space larger processing code smaller
yep smaller processing code than current
larger key space than current yeah okay
yeah yeah it's a lot a lot to go through
yeah it's I think one of the most
friendly ways of explaining like yeah we
get the big IOT explosion in terms of
the amount of devices okay it makes
sense that there that the way that
they're transmitting the data from their
sensor to the cloud or where it's being
stored or computed is needs to be
encrypted we get that part and then when
I think we get that it like currently on
the phones it's about three megabytes in
terms of how much storage you need to
for the software of encryption but you
guys brought it down to two kilobytes
and it's more sophisticated yeah and
it's so then that kind of and then the
sophistication how it's actually all
that side of things the keys and the
actual yeah how often you put them in
there half and you change them how well
lend to the security of the system and
the way we've done that the brilliance
and our engineers is that the way they
did that is really beneficial because it
can fit on those small devices in a
nutshell that's our business model it's
so interesting that there's like humans
that are so hyper specialized that know
how to do that and then there's like
humans specialize in all of the fields
and then there's also humans that focus
on like breadth of of knowledge instead
of depth yeah yeah I'm super breath and
so I like it whenever people go really
deep like hyper deep like level 10 or 50
didn't want depth on that those fields
it's hard to keep up so I'm trying to
constantly figure out how to keep up
when people talk trying to abstract a
layer a way up to try and explain and
understand surely what I'm sure this is
what I'm doing and then court some of
the companies that have come on board
for agile peak you already in yeah so we
have companies and we don't in some
cases we have nonce closure agreements
with companies so I'm a little careful
about naming names but I'll give you an
idea on prod
some of the things that we're using us
so there is a lot of IOT devices that
are started to be used in retail
merchandising so going into a retail
store in the future and some now instead
of seeing a printed pricing tag where
clerk comes by and if they want to
change the price of a bag of potato
chips they print out a new tag pull the
old one off put the new one on includes
the price the price per unit a barcode
some other things on that tag in that
pricing tag those are now being replaced
with LCD screens and those LCD screens
the pricing can be changed in a business
office so you can change pricing and for
retail stores oftentimes they can change
pricing several times during a day a
couple of examples it starts to rain and
your price on umbrellas is 10 bucks an
umbrella but you know you can raise that
to 12 because people are gonna be
running into keep their their their
bodies dry in the rain so they can raise
the price on those umbrellas when it
starts to rain
well that small increase can mean a lot
to profits or a retail store when
they're working on very very slender
margins so that kind of technology can
be very very beneficial it can reduce
the number of employees who have to put
pricing tags out and you can repurpose
those employees to greet customers and
show them to where they're where the
goods are that they're trying to buy so
an IOT cents around every retail item
and that can there can be that can
dynamically change the price on that
retail item yeah from a code deployment
rather than me yeah process and it
automatically changes it on that what
are called ESL tag electronic shelf
labeling tags
well those tags typically have our class
0 devices very small computing power and
no security on them so we went to market
with that and signed
a couple of contracts where we are now
providing security on those electronic
shelf labeling tax that's one
application another application where
we've signed to customers they have they
have developed asset tracking devices
that contract by GPS and a lot of
different factors they can track let's
say a shipping container on a ship or a
box that's going on an air freight or
another very interesting application
they have is they've developed a really
tremendous and sophisticated program
asset tracking program for police
evidence going into police departments
so that evidence isn't lost or misplaced
or when it's moved they know where it is
if it's if it's put in the wrong place
those are high-value assets yeah and so
they need the data going back and forth
to be secured so that people can't
intercept information about where a box
of high-value evidence is in a criminal
trial so they need security on those
kinds of things there is physical
security so there's all kinds of sensors
now that can increase physical security
everything from from heat sensors motion
sensors visual sensors gun shot sensors
that could alert a system to lock
certain things down say in a school if
there's an unfortunate incident like
happened in Gilroy they could lock
certain things down so that people can't
pass from area to area physical security
you don't want to be intercepted so the
bad actors could either shut that off or
know who's being alerted where consumer
devices there's lots and lots and lots
of consumer devices now that are being
connected to the Internet but they're
very small computing platforms and
oftentimes transactions are being
developed on those small computing
platforms and sent to a server for the
manufacturer of the device
but you don't want that information
exposed to the world you need to secure
that data transmission or what about for
a child's toy if it's connected to the
Internet so that there's learning and
there's all kinds of things that can
happen on a child's toy do you really
want somebody to have access to your
child's toy that could put up
inappropriate information on a screen
could make a connection with a child
somehow those kinds of communications
need to be secured so those are some of
the kinds of things that we we are doing
already smart cities there are sensors
all around cities like here in San
Francisco where there might be sensors
that count people as they go by our
count cars or see how fast people are
going or detect all kinds of weather
changes humidity changes that may affect
road conditions or sidewalk conditions
all of those kinds of things become
smart cities applications we have smart
cities contracts now those are some of
the kinds of things that we're securing
the data that's being collected damn
yeah that list of applications are so
long already and huge it's huge it's
huge and everything from yeah the smart
cities that you're describing all the
way to just knowing like just like
putting a massive code deployment out to
a bunch of IOT connected devices that
can then instantly make a change in the
environment yes it kind of do you ever
do you ever move couldn't you ever
concern yourself with like that that our
direction is that making us more safe or
is that making us you know how do you
feel about IOT yeah well right now
doesn't necessarily make us more safe
but it can make our world much much
better
just think of medical technology for one
you have implantable devices plantable
devices can be connected to the internet
and can be monitored by a server so that
if there is a medical condition that
could be life-threatening to someone it
can
detected very quickly and and and
medical help could be on the way very
very quickly it's a big one this
monitoring of biometric states for
predicting pathologies that's that's a
big one but but what if a bad actor yeah
in a nation state as an example who
didn't like the United States wanted to
figure out a way to hack a bunch of
devices and let's say there were ten
million devices implanted in people
around the country and they could
literally either shut them off or cause
malfunctions that could cause serious
health problems or in some cases death
yeah predictive crime analytics is also
an interesting one is it also makes it
seem a little bit like Big Brother as
well it does but I gotta tell you Alan a
while back somebody asked me what do you
think a big brother and don't shouldn't
should we even be doing this it should
the United States be looking I gotta
tell you everybody else is China is
watching you yeah but this isn't that
doesn't that kind of like get us to the
point of kind of like you know does
everyone need to be watching every one
or two we like more ethically or morally
evolved ourselves I don't think it's a
question of whether they should be it's
a question that they are how do you shut
that off
so what you what we need are people with
ethics and understanding and securing of
data in an appropriate way to be able to
better our world
I don't you you won't be able to turn
off the mass proliferation of collection
of data that's going on in today's world
it's only going to grow exponentially
yeah there's no way that one that feels
like this definitely feels like one of
those impossible but who knows you could
probably could possibly kick it off but
one person to try and take on eight
billion people that are all using all
the devices and the data proliferation
and all that stuff so then yeah the
companies are watching the governments
are watching too how do you do it in a
way that's a bin a bullet in a
benevolent way instead of amma level
way it's a major question to ask and
could we evolve ourselves spiritually so
that we don't necessarily need so much
oversight and need so much regulation on
all of these things so that's probably
that's probably the broad answer there
is to create people who have a greater
spiritual connection or a greater
ethical connection but bad actors are
always going to be there we often joke
that the IOT world is amazing
but but there's a lot of machines that
are having a lot of unprotected text
yeah in today's world and we we've got
to find ways to secure data in a way
that it can't just be proliferated and
used for clandestine purposes so
machines having unprotected text needs
to be stopped because there are
potentially malevolent actors and so
that by itself it's the proliferation of
machines it's gonna keep happening the
police data is gonna keep happening okay
so find security methods that truly
secure it yeah and spiritually evolve
ourselves to not need to even worry as
much about malevolent actors this is an
interesting dilemma that yeah it is it
is it's like we're compensating for our
lack of spiritual development with
securing with security with data
security and encryption and
yeah well it's the reason people in the
Middle Ages built fortresses with walls
that are very very high yeah that's
another way to look at it I mean it's
been going on since probably the day the
earth cooled I mean it's been going on
where you know the vast majority of
people are just good human beings people
want to be good they want to be ethical
they want to be good human beings but
there are those who take advantage of
that goodness and it always has been and
always will be so we won't stop and in
my view we shouldn't stop the
development of technology and the
proliferation of technology to better
our lives to to to reduce hunger to grow
crops better to to help monitor where
children are to help monitor bad actors
that seek to harm people those are all
very good uses of technology but they
they come at a price and that price so
we're constantly trying to find the
medieval wall if you will to to protect
against the the development of these
kinds of technologies that's what we're
involved in and if we go back in time to
Idaho Paul you know back as a kid you
know with family and with your neighbors
and just that purity and innocence of
just being there that world that doesn't
need the massive stone walls or moats
and it doesn't need all of the insane
amounts of encryption and Big Brother
nests
how does that feel well I tell my wife
all the time let's sell our house in the
city and just move out to the country
and I was respectful today I didn't wear
my cowboy boots but normally I've got
cowboy boots and and jeans on and you
know there there's a there's a great
appeal to that kind of thing but it
complicates our lives for me to be
traveling a much greater distance to get
to the office and all those kinds of
things so you protect your family and
you do what you need to to make sure
that you reduce stress in other ways and
in your life but there's a great appeal
to living in the land and off the land
and it's and it's a beautiful lifestyle
I mean you were born in South Dakota you
you know your roots go back there you
know the founder of our company who
developed the core technology lives in
North Dakota and still that still lives
there and doesn't want to move so he
commutes in to be with us periodically
there is a you know the hustle and
bustle the the commotion that is around
us can lead to a lot of a lot of stress
and in some cases can lead to
clandestine activities we see a lot of
homeless problem here in San Francisco
and and all around the country in major
cities and so forth the it leads to a
lot of problems but we're not going to
stop it people congregate together for
jobs and for hopefully for support and
being with neighbors and those kinds of
things too yeah the rush of the billions
of people to Metropolis is in that are
have yet to really graduate from
spiritual kindergarten in many ways
causing exacerbating further this
disconnection from each other this
disconnection from nature this
this propagation of of garbage is that
we have now in oceans and in landfills
and the lack of spiritual development is
just seems to be so evidently the reason
why we find so much mental health issues
so much distrust in each other and
having to spy on each other to secure
and encrypt things it's funny some
people say that we are exactly where
we're supposed to be like in terms of
our origin story and creation this is
exactly where were supposed to be right
now and dead we're on the Dow that we're
on the path and others say that work
weighed the buck off of the Dow were way
off of the path that the path is what we
were just describing a little bit ago
this this this young Paul and the farm
in Idaho in just having more innocence
and more purity and more spiritual
development where we don't need all the
Big Brother Ness pointed at all these
different countries that are all evolved
on the same rock where do you how do you
feel about about that all of that so I
so you mentioned earlier the concept of
I think it was emotional intelligence or
yeah that you talked about there are so
many forms of intelligence well one of
those forms of intelligence is
existential intelligence the
intelligence of understanding the
spiritual yeah I'm very much a believer
in that I am NOT a believer that we
should say to children I'm not going to
help you nurture your existential
intelligence where other types of
intelligence in you and you can decide
as you grow up on your own whether
whether there is such a thing as a
spiritual realm or or whether there is
such a thing as God I am a believer that
by making that decision you decided to
not have the spiritual training in a
child's life so yes a child can grow up
and decide to to believe a different way
that's fine that's their age
see to do that they have that personal
agency to do that so not inhibiting the
existential intelligence of every child
is I completely believe that they ought
to be exposed to that they ought to be
taught from the time they're very small
I was and I know I'm biased because of
that but I was taught that and it has
blessed my life and I taught my children
that not all of my children believe the
exact same thing they're not robots they
have their own mind but I believe
they're good ethical people do you
believe that we come from that single
source or that single origin I believe
that we are that yes that we have us
that we have an origin I believe in God
I believe we are our children of God I
believe that there is higher being and
that and that we have a purpose in life
and and that where were meant to fulfill
that purpose in in a mortal life I
believe that life itself is the
combination of an eternal spirit in a
physical mortal body hmm and I believe
that those are very real things and
because of that eternal spiritual part
of us we seek we wanted to be connected
yeah
with communication and we want to be
connected with the spiritual if we'll
let ourselves develop our spiritual
existential intelligence we can get
there very much a part of my life yeah
yeah it's beautiful hearing you talk
about it and it's actually really
important that more and more of the tech
and science leaders in Silicon Valley
and around the world find some sort of a
spiritual philosophical more
essential grounding as well because then
you can see how it becomes easier to
develop the world that we all want to
see whereas if it's just lack of
spiritual development that's developing
the world it's leads to catastrophe more
easily yeah this is this is this this
last portion it's been nice diving
deeper into the spiritual side of things
with you I yeah I enjoy that if any
anytime I can engage in these kinds of
discussions it's a real treat for me
it's it's part of what lights me up in
my life I love that I love that and then
out of the out of the spirituality that
you know that you've developed and that
you're also having with you know with
your children that is that it's coming
forth that if we are all then from that
same origin if we are all then from that
these children of God are these nerve
endings of God experiencing itself and
creating that is do you think that our
disconnection from that knowledge is the
reason why we have so many of the issues
I do think that there's a great deal of
truth to that I believe so I always told
my children I taught them to believe in
God but I told them if you don't believe
in God as you grow up find something
that's bigger than you hmm
because when we don't have something
bigger than us in life then all we have
is either money fame power greed greed
and and and ethics and values go out the
door they do yeah they they disappear we
have to have something bigger than us
that we that we pursue if something
bigger than us is working to alleviate
hunger among children around the world
great if something bigger than you is
belief in God and that drives you to to
help make the world a better place great
but we've got to have something that's
bigger than us because because that's
when life gets really worth living is
when we work for something bigger than
us yeah that's so beautifully said that
when we have some sort of a meaning we
can find any how to get there behind
this why and that we're just doing our
our best to achieve that then that North
Star that transcends us it transcends
our own timelines it transcends our our
own money greed corruption fame all
these things that you listed it because
we're doing something that's beyond us
and that ultimately that it makes it
totally feels like that coming from that
single origin and all expressing
ourselves that the more that we're
expressing ourselves selflessly for the
benefit of our families our communities
for others in the world that it just
feels a lot more meaningful yeah so in
our company
you know we're full of programmers and
tech types and so forth and and so we
have a we have a great work environment
and a great culture I mean you know we
have a unlimited vacation policies we
have all of these things that make life
easier to work for but there are a
couple of rules that we have one of the
rules that we have is that everybody
must engage in time every month in a
charitable cause they must and they have
to report what charity they work for and
what they did and we organize company
events to all go work at times for some
sort of charity or days when people can
all disperse and we'll let people off
for an afternoon or a day and they just
go work for something bigger than them
more important than writing another line
of code or making one more sales call or
raising one more dollar you know you
would love the last people we just
interviewed from fast forward
nonprofit tech companies that are doing
for social impact
the world so that could be something how
interesting - yeah - fun love them yeah
I haven't seen that episode I'll have to
go look yeah that one that's it that's
it that's a great one and I'm glad you
said that that's a critical policy and
community principle at work do you think
we're in a simulation I believe we're in
reality I believe that we're real
literal and physical because I have a
belief in God and I believe we are God's
children I believe that we are that it's
not a simulation it's it's real and it's
physical and then what do you think some
was a beautiful thing in the world a
newborn child a newborn animal birth is
and human beings I believe that's the
most beautiful thing in the world the
most magical thing I've ever experienced
is watching my kids be born most magical
thing I've ever experienced is watching
my wife birth that child and and seeing
the the love on her face and the instant
love you know I thought I understood
love you know when I had a girlfriend in
high school I thought I understood love
when I got married I thought I
understood love when I realized how much
my parents had done for me but none of
that compared to when I had a child and
the love that increased for my wife and
for that chat is the most beautiful
thing in the world to me just hands down
no question oh wow I love that and we
can almost also be birth every moment of
existence over and over again especially
when you gain new knowledge and it sinks
and that almost feels like you're being
born again when you see the world in a
new way
and like you said also that when a
partner gives birth to a child that the
unconditional love that they have for
that child that's another way to
understand love that first sight that's
it exists in in in many animal species
and so forth we used to you know we had
a lot of cattle on them on the ranch and
we would see those born all of time and
and chickens hatched and so forth way I
mean we to see the nesting and the love
and the care there's there's something
bigger than us that derives that kind of
level of spirituality and love yes
Paul this isn't such a pleasure thank
you thank you so much for coming on our
show of course what up what a pleasure
for me thank you thank you thank you
keep up the great work we'll keep
working at it I love it thank you thank
you thank you thank you everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it we'd
love to hear our thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking have more
conversation to your friends families
co-workers people online on social media
about post quantum IOT security about
our own spiritual development as well
how those two things interplay and all
the nuance that we described in that but
so check out a July you comm link in the
bio below also Paul's LinkedIn profile
and support the artists entrepreneurs
the spiritual leaders organizations
around the world that you believe in
supports simulation our links are below
patreon cryptocurrency paypal or design
cold merchants get paid link those are
all below and also thank you or shapiro
for producing the show greatly
appreciate it and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world we greatly appreciate you tuning
in thank you and we'll see you soon
much love peace